jean maxime bonjour alors sanofi vient
de racheter pour un peu plus de 3
milliards de dollars le spécialiste de
la rn messager qui est à la base des
vaccins tikva isr ou encore modern a
alors qu'on pensait que le groupe
français était sorti du jeu et du marché
des vaccins est ce que cela peut changer
ça veut dire quoi en terme de stratégie
eh bien écoutez ça veut dire que sanofi
serait engagée dans la recherche
vaccinale en investissant assez
massivement dans cette méthode de la rn
message et c'est la méthode vous le
disiez qui a été utilisé avec succès par
pfizer et modern art et qui au début
faisait un peu peur parce qu'elle était
très nouvelle c'est encore d'ailleurs
peur à tous ceux qui sont anti vaccins
par rapport au vaccin historiques tels
qu'ils ont été découverts tard pasteur
alors c'est vrai que un vaccin à
historique fait plus confiance notamment
un certain nombre de gens qui sont
méfiants les vaccins historique
reviennent à inoculer un virus à un peu
affaibli pour obliger nos cellules à
réagir et à fabriquer des anticorps ça
fait plus d'un siècle que ça existe à
glen messager eh bien on n'introduit pas
le mal on a trouvé pas le virus
on introduit une méthode pour apprendre
à notre cellule à se défendre alors
l'inconvénient est bien c'est que cette
même substance là et est assez fragile
difficile à transporter on ne sait elle
disparaît assez vite mais la cellule à
mémoriser le plan de bataille alors
sanofi s'est engagé dans ce secteur il
ya plusieurs mois sanofi avait déjà
annoncé des investissements massifs en
collaboration avec cette entreprise
américaine 36 lettres bio voilà que
sanofi rachète maintenant purement et
simplement l'entreprise ça prouve deux
choses
ça prouve que sanofi croit énormément
dans cet axe de recherche et que la
lutte contre le comité loin d'être
terminée va falloir vacciner encore le
monde entier et sans doute refaire assez
souvent des vaccins on parle
actuellement la nécessité d'une
troisième jour d'une troisième dose
notamment pour les personnes les plus
âgées et la suite dépendra évidemment
des variants parce qu'il faut adapter le
vaccin h1 femmes et deuxième chose
sanofi croit surtout à cette technique
de la rn messager pour lutter contre les
cancers parce qu'on a découvert la rn
messager il ya plus de 15 ans maintenant
le cadre de recherche contre le cancer
et on a découvert son utilité contre le
coc vide presque par hasard et c'est
pour ça que la reine âgées a autant de
succès aujourd'hui
alors pourquoi justement sanofi a pris
du retard dans la recherche du vaccin
écoutez sanofi a pris du retard parce
que sanofi travaillais je vous le disais
sur des vaccins classiques qui demande
beaucoup beaucoup de vérifications
beaucoup beaucoup d'investissements des
années et des années en général une
dizaine d'années et avec le co vide et
bien on a vu les arènes message est
arrivé sur le marché très vite dès le
mois de septembre de l'année alors je
pense que sanofi à des prix cours et les
dirigeants de sanofi savent très bien
que pour gagner il fallait être les
premiers on dépense énormément d'argent
c'est un peu comme les tickets de loto
et puis on a assez peu de chances de
gagner
on gagne si on est les premiers et ils
ne pouvaient pas être le premier alors
l'investissement est considérable il
faut beaucoup d'argent je vous le disais
pour obtenir les tests donc sanofi est
sorti du jeu ils n'ont pas mesuré
l'impact que ça pouvait avoir en terme
d'image notamment pour l'europe
notamment pour la france
ils n'ont pas abandonné pour autant
puisqu'il travaille actuellement donc
sur deux vaccins un vaccin classique
type pasteur qui sortira sans doute là
maintenant on le sait en décembre et un
vaccin avec la rn message et qu'ils vont
finalement faire avec cette biotech
américaine 37 les deux vaccins pourrait
donc sortir à la fin de cette année est
ce que ça veut dire que sanofi a les
moyens de tenir tête aux grandes
multinationales jean-marc oui parce que
sanofi en a pris un coup sur l'image
c'est sûr et cela nos filles est encore
aujourd'hui un acteur majeur de
l'industrie pharmaceutique mondiale
alors c'est une entreprise d'origine
française dont les labos sont
principalement en france dont les usines
sont principalement en france mais c'est
une entreprise qui est très
internationalisées au niveau du capital
les investisseurs français possède à peu
près 35 % du capital
le premier actionnaire et d'ailleurs est
aujourd'hui le real et 70% du capital
est détenu par des fonds américains
anglais et européen ou qatari et au
niveau des ventes plus de la moitié des
chiffres d'affaires est réalisé à
l'étranger et malgré le loupé du vaccin
anti covit qui va faire la fortune de
files ro2 moderna sanofi reste un
champion du monde de l'industrie des
vaccins avec notamment tous les vaccins
pour les enfants et notamment celui de
la méningite dans le monde entier on
utilise le vaccin sanofi sanofi a une
division grand public qui est très
prospère avec le doliprane justement
c'est eux et les médicaments tous les
médicaments beaucoup dermatologiques
aussi je reviens sur le doliprane dont
les ventes ont explosé avec le co vide
puisque au départ on n'avait pas ça on
avait que ça pour calmer la fièvre donc
sanofi aura les moyens de satisfaire la
demande d'autant que vous avez une bonne
partie des français
ici on récalcitrants à la vaccination
les personnels soignants en patch assez
souvent qu'ils accepteraient des
vaccinés avec introduit sanofi parce
qu'ils auraient plus confiance donc il
faut absolument sanofi sortons 25 ou et
très vite sans doute la fin d'année une
entreprise en bonne santé donc mais qui
réduit ses effectifs avec des plans de
restructuration qui inquiète les
syndicats
c'est pas un petit peu contradictoire
alors écoutez si ça peut apparaître
contrôle tard mais comme toutes les
grandes entreprises françaises sanofi
n'a cédé à la céder à la tentation
délocalisé au cours des 15 dernières
années les effectifs ont beaucoup baissé
moins de travail en usine c'est vrai
parce qu'ils ont plus de délocalisations
en inde ou en chine
quant aux chercheurs certains ont cédé
aux sirènes américaines et à moins d'un
an le projet de restructurer t les
effectifs à d'ailleurs avait été bloquée
un par bercy mais il reste un plan de
départs volontaires qui serait en cours
de négociation dit dont on parle de 400
chercheurs sur des effectifs qui
dépassent plus de soixante mille
personnes
donc ça n'est pas rien on verra si
l'acquisition de cette entreprise
américaine relance la recherche et se
traduit par le rapatriement de salariés
dans l'hexagone ou alors au contraire
par le départ de certains vers
l'amérique là c'est un point
d'interrogation
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre pour
toutes ces précisions jean-marc à ses
vestes journaliste et éditorialiste
économique